Our third example is about
the Framingham Heart Study.
This study represents one of
the most important studies
of modern medicine.
It is an ongoing
study of the residents
in Framingham, Massachusetts.
It started in 1948, and is
now on the third generation.
Much of the now-common knowledge
regarding heart disease
came from this study.
For example, the fact
that high blood pressure
should be treated.
Clogged arteries are not normal.
Cigarette smoking can
lead to heart disease.
Let us give some statistics
about heart disease.
Heart disease has been
the leading cause of death
worldwide since the 1920s.
7.3 million people died from
coronary heart disease in 2008.
Since 1950, age-adjusted
death rates have declined 60%.
In part, due to the results
of the Framingham Heart Study.
What is the data in this study?
There were 5,209 patients
enrolled in 1948.
The patients were given
a questionnaire and exams
every two years, measuring
their physical characteristics,
their behavioral
characteristics,
and medical test results.
The patient population, the
exams, and the questions
expanded over time.
The approach the Framingham
Heart Study utilized
was a regression to
predict whether or not
a patient would develop heart
disease in the next 10 years.
The model tested and adjusted
for different populations.
The results of the study
are available online
so users can calculate
their risk of heart disease
based on total cholesterol, HDL,
and systolic blood pressure.
So what is the edge?
It provided necessary evidence
for the development of drugs
to lower blood pressure.
The study further paved the way
for other cliniical prediction
rules that predict clinical
outcomes using patient's data.
Finally, the study
demonstrated how
a model allows a
medical professional
to make predictions
for patients worldwide.